suche nach frieden einen gipfel in paris
soll helfen den konflikt in der ukraine
zu lösen neue massive dopingsperre
russland darf vier jahre lang nicht zu
weltmeisterschaften und olympia und
tödlicher vulkanausbruch in neuseeland
sterben mindestens fünf menschen viele
werden noch vermisst
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster nachrichten um 7 für den
sport ist wieder kristin otto an meiner
seite mit handball und wintersport guten
abend es ist ein neuer anlauf den
festgefrorenen konflikt in der ost
ukraine zu lösen nach drei jahren
funkstille
zum ersten mal trifft dabei der
ukrainische präsident sie lenski auf
russlands präsident putin diesmal in
paris und wieder unter vermittlung von
bundeskanzlerin merkel und frankreichs
präsident makro ein quartett auf
schwieriger mission wie und wann der
konflikt überhaupt entstanden ist dazu
jetzt erst einmal caroline wie man ende
präsident janukowitsch entscheidet sich
überraschend gegen einen
annäherungsabkommen mit der eu
wochenlang protestieren tausende auf dem
majdan in kiew bei gefechten mit
sicherheitskräften sterben dutzende
menschen janukowitsch flieht das land
tief gespalten
im westen überwiegend eu orientierte
ukraine im osten eine starke bindung zu
russland märz 2014 russland annektiert
die krim in der ost ukraine bricht krieg
aus separatisten dort fordern
unabhängigkeit unterstützt mit waffen
und soldaten aus russland alle abkommen
zum waffenstillstand scheitern fast
täglich sterben soldaten und zivilisten
die bilanz bisher 13.000 tote 1,5
millionen menschen sind im eigenen land
auf der flucht
auf beiden präsidenten selensky wie
putin lastet ein ziemlicher druck auf
sie lenski weil er große erwartungen
geweckt hat und auf putin weile auf die
neue friedensinitiative reagieren muss
und auch die bundeskanzlerin und der
französische präsident haben sich viel
vorgenommen
bernhard lichter berichtet
bundeskanzlerin merkel traf als erste im
elysée palast ein
das deutsch französische tandem will
mehr sein als nur mediator steht fast
unter erfolgszwang
die kanzlerin hatte ihre teilnahme an
einer neuauflage des normandie formats
in der vergangenheit immer an die
aussicht auf substanzielle fortschritte
geknüpft wurde die mesa lenski der neue
mann in kiew steht zumindest für
bewegung er wolle den krieg beenden
koste es was es wolle
hatte er vor seiner wahl erklärt der
russische präsident hat allerdings
bislang nicht erkennen lassen ob er die
ost ukraine wieder aus seiner
einflusssphäre entlassen will
dennoch gab es im vorfeld des gipfels in
teilbereichen ein aufeinander zu
die brücke des friedens instanz sei
lohans gar 2015 zerstört verbindet die
separatisten gebiete seit kurzem wieder
mit dem ukrainischen kern land gefangene
wurden ausgetauscht
oft nach jahren der isolation noch immer
aber sitzen hunderte 1
im november schließlich der einstieg in
eine truppen entflechtung die seit
langem auf eis willens gedrängt auf
frieden
wir brauchen einen waffenstillstand der
nicht nur zwei oder drei tage hält mit
klaren bedingungen und verpflichtungen
der gipfel von paris soll den dauerhaft
bringen
länger als geplant die einzelgespräche
viel später auch der beginn der großen
runde
das muss kein schlechtes zeichen sein
wir haben auch sitzen sie zusammen
trotzdem schon mal die frage an unseren
paris korrespondenten thomas walde gibt
dieses treffen denn irgendeinen anlass
zu optimismus also der élysée hat
verlauten lassen ein erster erfolg sei
dass dieses treffen überhaupt zustande
gekommen sei das ist ja seit 2016 nicht
mehr der fall gewesen
dann treffen sie lenski und putin hier
zum ersten mal aufeinander und wir hören
wollen sie am abend auch zu einem
bilateralen gespräch zusammen kommen das
war vorher zumindest so nicht
angekündigt worden
die verhandlungsdelegation aller vier
länder haben zuvor schon wie wir hören
eine recht umfangreiche liste erarbeitet
mit konkreten maßnahmen die hier
verabschiedet werden soll
maßnahmen zur truppen entflechtung zur
vertrauensbildung humanitäre maßnahmen
zur verlängerung des waffenstillstandes
ein neuer gefangenenaustausch ob das
alles von den vier chefs dann am ende
wirklich so verabschiedet wird das muss
man noch abwarten
deutsche und französische diplomaten
warnen vor allzu viel optimismus sie
sagen ein politischer durchbruch der sei
hier
zumal putin seelands geht das erste mal
sich überhaupt sehen nicht zu erhalten
die einschätzung von thomas walde vielen
dank dafür nach paris um russland geht
es auch bei unserem nächsten thema denn
das land bekam heute eine historisch
hohe dopingstrafe die
welt-anti-doping-agentur wada schloss
russland für vier jahre von den
wichtigsten sportveranstaltungen aus von
den olympischen spielen und den
weltmeisterschaften inklusive fußball
die begründung der wade russland habe
manipulierte doping daten geliefert
michael kreuz berichtet es ist ein novum
der beschluss der
welt-anti-doping-agentur wada der diese
weitreichenden folgen für russland haben
soll
die konsequenzen beinhalten die
verbannung russlands von olympischen
spielen paralympics und allen
weltmeisterschaften für vier jahre und
ebenso das verbot solche
großveranstaltungen in diesem zeitraum
auszurichten
[Musik]
die teilnahme an der fußball-em 2020 als
kontinentale sportereignis bliebe davon
unberührt bei der wm 2022 in katar wäre
russland dagegen nicht dabei erneut nur
unter neutraler flagge können russische
athleten bei den nächsten beiden
olympischen spielen starten und auch nur
dann wenn sie nachweisen dass ihre daten
nicht manipuliert worden sind denn das
ist laut wada an diesem moskauer
kontrolllabor passiert in dem labor
wurden dopingproben versteckt wurden
also nicht der wahre gemeldet und diese
diese ergebnisse die damals durchgeführt
worden sind insbesondere vom doktor
chekov die haben wir jetzt alle und
deswegen können wir auch alle ergebnisse
entsprechend bewerten
allerdings ist die einsicht in russland
begrenzt ein dopingproblem wird zwar
eingeräumt aber regierungschef medwedew
sagt auch bitten zufrieden es ist eine
fortsetzung der antirussischen history
die bereits chronisch geworden ist
dementsprechend befürwortet er einen
einspruch und dann muss der
internationale sportgerichtshof cas die
entscheidung treffen
russische athleten dürfen also
teilnehmen aber nicht unter russischer
flagge markus harmlos an
wie schätzen sie dieses urteil ein nun
ist klingt erst mal wie eine richtig
harte strafe doch wie so oft steckt der
teufel im detail die russen werden nicht
komplett ausgeschlossen
es gibt reichlich hintertürchen für sie
so kann es sein dass bei den olympischen
spielen in tokio im sommer so genannte
neutrale athleten aus russland an den
start gehen werden und wir in pyongyang
bei den winterspielen zuletzt ein
riesiges team stellen werden ob das denn
sauber ist wer weiß die russen haben bis
zuletzt alle daten und proben
manipuliert nachweis nicht möglich und
russische sponsoren sollten wohl nicht
verprellt werden geld so kann man denken
steht immer noch vor einem sauberen
sport
aktiven geht daher dieses urteil auch
nicht weit genug viele aus der wade
athletenkommission hatten einen komplett
ausschluss der russen gefordert doch
dieses urteil ist wahrscheinlich
sicherer und leichter durchzubringen vor
dem cast dem obersten sportgerichtshof
der welt als eben eine komplette rote
karte für alle russen und kas der
entscheidet schlussendlich vielen dank
markus haben alter wein in neuen
schläuchen so oder so ähnlich tönt es
heute aus der union
die ist nämlich wenig begeistert von dem
was ihr koalitionspartner auf dem
parteitag am wochenende beschlossen hat
die spd fordert unter anderem den
mindestlohn zu erhöhen auf bis zu 12
euro
außerdem höhere co2 abgaben zum
kinderschutz genetischer zeigt die
reaktion telefoniert hat an den geriet
kramp karrenbauer schon mit der neuen
spd-spitze treffen will man sich noch
vor weihnachten eine haltung aber hat
die union bereits verabredet mann ist
geschlossen liegen jede nachfahren
es geht jetzt nicht darum
entgegenzukommen also ich meine jetzt
die tatsache ist die spd hat zwei neue
parteivorsitzende hatten wir letztes
jahr auch da haben wir auch nicht
angefangen also es muss jetzt irgendwo
ein begrüßungsgeschenk geben und das
wird es mit uns auch nicht geben
und schon gar nicht wird es eine rütteln
an der schwarzen null oder gar an der
schuldenbremse geben die in der
verfassung festgeschrieben ist was nicht
gehen wird die nächsten zwei jahre sind
so schwarze-peter-spiel oder rotes
linien hopping offenheit gibt es aber
bei einzelnen themen beispiel
mindestlohn
der arbeitnehmerflügel der cdu hat
grundsätzlich verständnis für einen
höheren mindestlohn verantwortlich sei
dafür aber nicht die große koalition
sondern die eingesetzte mindestlohn
kommission und die habe schlecht
gearbeitet
das gesetz sagt er will es nun so so
steigen wie die löhne sind man muss aber
auch bedenken dass die leute davon leben
können müssen wenn sie single sind und
das ist auch für die rente reichen muss
und die mindestlohn-kommission hat nur
stur lohnerhöhungen umgesetzt hat die
anderen dinge nicht gesehen von neuen
wünschen beim thema klima muss die große
koalition erst mal ihr schon
beschlossenes klimapaket hier durch den
vermittlungsausschuss bekommen sonst
wird es zum beispiel nichts mit
günstigeren bahn tickets ab ersten
januar
es war am freitagabend in augsburg bei
einem streit auf offener straße wird ein
feuerwehrmann niedergeschlagen und
stirbt jetzt hat die polizei details zur
tat bekannt gegeben
gegen sieben junge männer seien
haftbefehle erlassen worden
dem hauptverdächtigen wird totschlag
vorgeworfen petra neubauer
sie sind an den tatort gekommen um
mitgefühl zu zeigen und kurz
innezuhalten
noch immer ist das entsetzen der
menschen in augsburg groß wie kann man
so was macht das verstehe ich nicht
wir sind doch um menschen und keine
beste das könnte auch mein vater sein
damit es meiner mutter kinderstadt
beleuchtung wenn das sowas passiert das
geht einfach gar nicht am freitagabend
gegen 23 uhr wollen zwei ehepaare vom
weihnachtsmarkt nach hause am
königsplatz geraten die männer in einen
wortwechsel mit einer gruppe
jugendlicher plötzlich wird der
49-jährige mann attackiert dann gab es
einen schlag der schlag war unvermittelt
von der seite und mit voller wucht und
hat so zum tode geführt
der freund des mannes wird ebenfalls
verletzt
alles festgehalten von
überwachungskameras vor allem dadurch
gelingt es der polizei die sieben
verdächtigen schnell zu identifizieren
und festzunehmen alle sind in augsburg
geboren 6 sind deutsche staatsangehörige
wir haben bei fünf der täter auch andere
zum teil auch andere nämlich türkische
staatsangehörigkeit einmal italienische
staatsangehörigkeit und der eine ist
auch libanesische staatsangehörige gegen
alle ist inzwischen haftbefehl wegen
totschlags beziehungsweise beihilfe zum
totschlag erlassen worden
am abend treffen sich viele feuerwehren
wie hier in delmenhorst zu einer
schweigeminute gedenken an eine tat die
bundesweit berührt die dlrg schlägt
alarm immer weniger kinder können
schwimmen lernen weil viele bäder
schließen
die lebensretter fordern deshalb 14
milliarden euro um beta zu erhalten
laut dlrg gab es im jahr 2000 noch rund
7800 schwimmbäder 2018 waren es nur noch
6400 laut umfrage aus dem jahr 2017 sind
mehr als die hälfte der 10 jährigen
keine sicheren schwimmer die forderungen
der lebensretter liegt nun beim
petitionsausschuss des bundestages
batterien für elektroautos sind das
wichtigste bauteil und kommen bislang
vor allem aus asien
nur drei prozent werden in europa gebaut
das soll sich ändern
deswegen hat die eu kommission jetzt
einem massiven subventions plan
zugestimmt sieben eu länder darunter
deutschland und frankreich dürfen
heimische unternehmen unterstützen
insgesamt mit 3,2 milliarden euro das
ziel technisch aufholen und
arbeitsplätze sichern
panzer kampfflugzeuge oder kriegsschiffe
weltweit läuft das geschäft mit gross
waffen
laut dem schwedischen
friedensforschungsinstituts sipri
verkauften die 100 größten
rüstungskonzerne 2018 groß waffen im
wert von 380 milliarden euro 46 prozent
mehr als 2000 17 größte exporteur
bleiben die usa die deutschen konzerne
setzten dagegen 3,8 prozent weniger um
chinas bilanz konnte nicht erfasst
werden
wegen fehlender darf die ureinwohner
neuseelands nennen vaccari den
dramatischen vulkan
nun ist er ausgebrochen mit dramatischen
folgen
mindestens fünf menschen kamen ums leben
das auswärtige amt geht davon aus dass
unter den verletzten auch deutsche sind
der vaccari liegt vor der nordküste
neuseelands auf island die kleine insel
ist unbewohnt aber jedes jahr kommen
rund 10.000 besucher wegen des vulkans
etwa 50 waren hier auch am krater
unterwegs als plötzlich asche in den
himmel schoss normen odenthal berichtet
50 kilometer vom festland entfernt aber
nicht zu übersehen die aschewolke des
bakari neuseelands aktivster vulkan
trotzdem kommt die eruption für die
touristen völlig unerwartet plötzlich
und mit enormer kraft einige wandern da
gerade am rande des kraters von einem
augenblick auf den anderen sind die
urlauber in lebensgefahr weg vom vulkan
weg von der insel das schaffen nicht
mehr alle rechtzeitig es gibt tote und
verletzte
wir können noch immer nicht genau sagen
wie viele menschen vom ausbruch
betroffen sind wir versuchen aktuell so
schnell und effizient wie möglich die
exakten zahlen zu bekommen
vor allem ist unklar wie viele menschen
noch immer auf der insel sind verletzte
sind aufs festland geflogen wurden mit
brandwunden aber in sicherheit die
rettungsflüge mussten bald eingestellt
werden der auch die asche machten den
einsatz zu gefährlich sagt die polizei
und wer jetzt noch nicht gefunden wurde
habe höchstwahrscheinlich nicht überlebt
das könnten mehr als 20 menschen seien
heisst es doch gewissheit gibt es nicht
die lage ist instabil sagen uns die
geologen es besteht die möglichkeit
weitere eruptionen im moment ist für die
rettungskräfte eine rückkehr auf die
insel deshalb zu riskant forscher sollen
kürzlich erhöhte aktivität des vulkans
gemessen haben warum die touristen die
insel dennoch besuchen durften gehört zu
den fragen die es zu klären
wir sind beim sport und da gab es leider
einen dämpfer für die deutschen
handballerinnen christin eine echt
ärgerliche niederlage hängende köpfe in
japan nach dem 28 29 gegen serbien
ein sieg hätte die wm halbfinale
teilnahme bedeutet der showdown steigt
nun am mittwoch im letzten
hauptrundenspiel gegen
rekord-europameister norwegen
hoffentlich dann mit dem besseren ende
einen siebenmeter 5 sekunden vor schluss
sorgt für klarheit und ernüchterung
nicht stevic gegen torfrau eckerle 29 zu
28 für serbien die erste niederlage in
der hauptrunde
nach der bisher schwächsten deutschen
leistung weil nicht klar ist dass man am
ende kommt keine punkte deutschland ist
gegen den em fünften serbien fast nur
mit tempo gegenstößen gefährlich
dabei wird amelie berger mit insgesamt
sechs treffern neben index kaya beste
werferin drei tore rückstand aufgeholt
kurz vor schluss sogar noch eine
deutsche führung trotzdem die niederlage
jetzt muss ein sieg im nächsten spiel
gegen norwegen her um das minimalziel
olympia qualifikation noch zu erreichen
[Applaus]
stefan kunz hat seinen vertrag als
trainer der deutschen fußball und 20
nationalmannschaft vorzeitig verlängert
bis ende juli 2000 23
der 57-jährige hatte die dfb-auswahl
mitte 2016 übernommen im jahr darauf zum
em titel sowie diesen sommer ins
em-finale geführt und zum wintersport
und zwei deutschen weltcup siegen am
späten abend in nordamerika viktoria
rebensburg fuhr im kanadischen lake
louise ihrer lieblingsdisziplin dem
super-g bestzeit von oben bis unten wie
an der schnur gezogen eine augenweide so
das übereinstimmende lob nach ihrem
eindrucksvollen triumph und im
amerikanischen lake placid raste
francesco friedrich mit anschieber
alexander schüler im zweierbob auf platz
eins vor teamkollege johannes lochner
der am tag zuvor gewonnen hatte zwei
schöne
wir haben jetzt noch was neues von den
kleinen pandabären im berliner zoo wies
die chinesische tradition vorschreibt
haben nach 100 tagen die kleinen
zwillinge einen namen bekommen mengen
joanne und mengen zu deutsch erfüllter
traum und ersehnter traum die vorschläge
hong und kommen hatten sich nicht
durchgesetzt
bis die schwarz-weißen kirchenbesucher
zu sehen bekommen dauert es allerdings
noch ein paar wochen zum wetter an den
alpen soll es morgen zeitweise schneien
im norden wird es dagegen sonnig zu den
einzelheiten gleich gunther tiersch das
war's danke für ihr interesse
das heute journal mit marietta slomka um
21.45 und wir sind morgen abend wieder
zur stelle punkten
schönen abend noch bis dann
[Musik]
mit liebe zuschauer unser wetter wird
kühler und so gibt es auch wieder schnee
die temperaturen morgen in mitteleuropa
erreichen nur so werte um die fünf grad
kalt winterlich kalt ist es in
skandinavien dauerfrost null bis minus
zehn grad das sind ja auch schon die
höchsttemperaturen und auch in der
kommenden nacht gibt es bei uns leichten
frost verbreitet in deutschland nur an
den küsten bleibt es frostfrei und es
kann sehr sehr glatt werden uns
überqueren ja noch regen und
schneeschauer nach südosten und vor
allen dingen den mittelgebirgen schneit
dabei aber eben auch südlich der donau
an den alpen kurzzeitig frischt der wind
auf stürmische böen gibt es aus
nordwesten im laufe der nacht morgen
vormittag schneit dann auch noch direkt
an den alpen gibt es vielleicht auch
schneeschauer im erzgebirge sonst wird
es freundlich mit sonne und wolken im
norden und westen nachmittags letzter
schneefall an den alten dann wieder nach
dafür wird aber hier im nordwesten
bewölkter der wind frischt auf
es gibt die ersten stürmischen böen aus
südwesten an der nordsee
die temperaturen erreichen in bayern und
mittelgebirgen nur so 0 bis 4 grad sonst
sind es fünf bis sieben grad und die
aussichten ziemlich nass kann man sagen
allerdings mit schnee am mittwoch in den
mittelgebirgen ist wird auch stürmisch
dazu donnerstag ist es ruhiger aber am
freitag gibt sturm es gibt schnee und
regen ich wünsche noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie es gut